Bhoochetana Department
of Agriculture Presents
ICRISAT DigitalGreen KSDA
Coconut planting method
Namaste my dear farmer friends.
My name is Basavaraj.
I work with Icrisat
company as a researcher.
Our farmers grow a lot, but
while growing coconuts
if they want to know how to do so
they would need information.
We will talk to the
Horticultural department
about how to plant saplings
from their researcher
Please take full advantage of this.
Sir, Namaste.
Namaste. My name is Basavaraj.
I work with Icrisat company as a researcher
We want to teach our farmers
on how to plant coconut saplings
My name is Dr. M. Prashant
I work as a sapling
researcher and look after
farm management. Yes, Mr Basavaraj
A lot of farmers are coming and
we tell them to change their
planting methods.
A lot of farmers
hesitate to implement our method.
They doubt it. One doubt is that
we tell them to make a 3 feet deep
3 feet wide and 3 feet long ditch.
And we tell them to plant it.
We tell the farmers this.
Farmers doubt this because
the saplings will be of this size.
So they think- why should they make
such a big ditch and plant it.
This is their doubt. Can you show us a
demo on how plan the sapling?
Okay Mr. Basavaraj, like you said,
I will show them
how to plant, measure
and mix it.
And how to plant it, support it and
fasten it, I will show you the demo
Come let us go see the demo
One meter means 3.3 feet
3.3 feet depth, width and length
Mr. Basavaraj
I will show you how to plant saplings
You should pay a lot of attention
and understand it, so now
You have to make a ditch like this
which measures 3 feet in depth, width and
3 feet length
After making the ditch
it is very important to
know how to fill it up
To fill this ditch
the soil that was removed is here
Along with it you have to mix sand
with sand you have to mix manure
mix it in a 1:1:1 ratio
which means 1 part sand
1 part manure and
1 part red soil or excavated soil
you have to mix all these
three and fill the ditch
Once you have filled the ditch if possible
you can make a waterway
we have to give water route
once it is closed and watered the soil
goes down by one or two inches
Why do we add sand?
We add sand because
coconuts attract
white ants
White ants will eat the sapling
and kill it, since there is manure
we have to add
sand, red soil
and Dimet to stop white ants
We use Dimet for white ants
This how you fill
the ditch
and prepare it
Mr. Basavaraj, as you can see
we have filled the ditch with equal
amounts of sand, manure and soil
After it is levelled like this
we will tie ropes like this
while plating
we tie ropes, when they are tied
we get the pit’s centre point
So we tie a rope like this
on both sides
then you get the center point
and mark it.
Now we will remove soil with a spade
After removing the soil
not too deep
people have misunderstood
that we will plant it 3 feet under
it is a misunderstanding,
everyone says that
and then add Dimet or Foret into the ditch
to avoid white ants
it has to be mixed like this
2 spoons are enough? Yes it is enough
Can you smell it now? Yes
You will get a foul smell
and insects stay away
While planting this, you
have to keep in mind that
You will have to plant it
usually like this
1 inch above the coconut
If you add more than this
the sapling will get disease
because mud will enter
this part
To avoid this
and prevent this
we will plant it in the centre
and fill the soil one
inch above the coconut
After planting it like this
then
you can see the leaves are like fans
when it is windy
they move
to avoid this we will
plant a stick next to it
and compact the surrounding
with your feet and
If you have drip system, you can install it
If not, you have to
pour water from the top
The plant will settle well
after it is set
we will tie
it to the stick
This will avoid
falling from wind
and setting of the roots
After watering it what to do next?
No, nothign else, If you want to you can
add more soil here
and level and compact it with your feet
If you compact it the plant will not shake
and will grow properly
You have ties the plant to the stick
Yes it is very important
Once it is planted
the coconut will be inside
we have to keep pushing it below
also not to let the mud get in here
but dont push it too deep
like the proverb
“Walk straight like a coconut tree”
so we make a 3 by 3 by 3 ditch
and we have filled it with
soil, manure and sand and planted it
Notice that that we have made PP on these
because of this
and the leaves being like a fan
it moves when there is wind
When it moves so much
the roots wont set well
and the plant may die
to avoid that we have this stick here
and tied the leaves to it
and also the steam
whne you tie it
this plant wont move in the wind
and no other problem will occur
and it will have good roots
and will grow properly
What is the distance between
the saplings? Length and breath?
can you explain it in detail
If you want to make a coconut grove
then you will have to 7.5 meters
between saplings and rows
that is if you want to make a coconut grove
some farmer wants to
grow crops with coconuts
we have to increase the distance
between saplings and rows
Here we have left 7.5 meters
Only to make a coconut grove? Yes
So according we have planted it
With this spacing how many
can we plant in an acre? If we have a
distance of 7.5 meters then
in 1 hectare we can have 177 trees
which is in 2.5 acres
So for 1 acer
if you do it the old way
they will have 30 feet distance
if you do it like that then
in 1 acer you can have 40 trees
and in 1 hectare you can have 120 trees
so when you plant like this
you can have 177 trees which is more
trees in a particular area
and we will get more profit
Mr. Basavaraj, even if you want to plant
on the main farm area we have to
follow a certain procedure.
Because, if we do not follow it properly
the rows will not be aligned
They will not be straight
and when the distance is not equal
the farm will look bad
because of the planting methods
To avoid this, we should first make a baseline
From the boundary of the property
you have to leave 7.5 metres
How much distance? 7.5 meters
and then make the baseline
after making the line
You should make markers at both the ends
of the baseline and attach thread
it will come out straight
Once this is done we
have to make another baseline like this
once this is done measure
the angle at this corner
and they should be right angle
with the help of tape
then what ever you will plant
it will be at a distance of 7.5 meters
and then the rows will look aligned
from all directions
even diagonally they look aligned
If you see it straight or cross
or from any corner they will look aligned
You can notice that in this farm
at our main farm you can see it
from here you have mark 7.5 meters
and here on this row
We mark 7.5 meters and
will tie a rope
and mark 7.5 meters here as well
and place stick here
The place where the stick is will be the
centre of the pit and dig it
centre the sticks and dig the pit
yes dig the pit
After making the pits
next we should mix
in equal quantities manure, soil and sand
and fill the pit
So if we plan the
pits and fill it
and then plant
here you can see North to south
the rows are straight, also form the sides
rows look straight
and also from east to west the
So when we plan like this
we can have a planned farm
and we can provide nutrition and minerals
equally to all the pants
and the plants will grow
well and more output
Up until now, you have taught
our farmer friends
how to plant coconut saplings
to dig a pit
We thank Prashant Sir and
and the horticulture research centre
the staff and the staff here
on behalf of us and all the farmers
I thank you again. Namaste.
Similarly I would like to say that
Because of your department,
the farmers are able to
share this research with
them and inform them
about how to plant the saplings.
Through us, you are able
to show the farmers
I would like to thank you and your team
on behalf of us and our research
I thank you very much.
Summary questions: 1. How big should
the pit be to plant a coconut sapling?
2. What are the materials
to be filled in the pit?
3. How much distance should be
there between the saplings?
Researcher: Dr. M. Prashant, HRS.
Camera: Renuka Murthy, Volunteer,
Horticulture Department
Actor: Basavaraju RT,
ICRISAT Technical advice: